- [Instructor] I had never been curious
about my family history,
but a rumored link in my lineage
to Genghis Khan piqued my interest.
I wonder if this was written
for me in particular.
But anyway, back to the sentence.
So they've underlined piqued,
and this form of piqued,
or this spelling of piqued,
P-I-Q-U-E-D, one meaning
of it is to stimulate.
And so this would be
stimulated my interest,
which is exactly what the person
saying the sentence wants to say,
that this rumored link
stimulated their interest.
So this, another way,
stimu, let me write this,
stimulated their interest,
which makes a lot of sense.
And just the phrase, piqued my interest,
is something that you would
hear a lot and it's spelled,
the piqued part is spelled P-I-Q-U-E-D.
Now, piqued could mean other things.
It could mean to irritate.
But especially when people are talking
about piqued my interest,
hey, that piqued my interest,
that means hey, that
stimulated my interest.
So this is the right spelling.
This is the right use of it.
So I would say NO CHANGE.
Now, let's look at these other choices
just to make sure that we feel good
about ruling them out.
So peak, P-E-A-K, that's
like a mountain peak,
so the top of the mountain.
That's a mountain peak.
So if you use it as a verb,
you could say he peaked the mountain,
which means that he got to
the top of the mountain.
But that's not what we're
talking about right over here.
Now P-E-E-K, that's the kind of, you know,
look when you're not
supposed to, so to speak.
You know, he peeked through the keyhole,
or she peeked through her fingers
when she was It playing hide-and-go-seek.
To peek, this is kinda just to kinda look
when you're not supposed to.
So peek, or to kinda look
very, kinda very quickly.
So that wouldn't be it.
And opaqued, well, this is
doesn't even sound the same.
At least these first three,
piqued, peaked, and peeked,
they all sound the same.
But opaque, opaque means something
that you can't see through.
And so I guess opaqued
would mean, you know,
I guess if you had a,
imagine if you had a window.
I've actually never used the word opaqued
in everyday language,
but if you had a window that is clear
and then you paint it with stuff
that you can't see through,
I guess you would have
opaqued that window.
So anyway, I would rule
that one out as well.